[inaudible] joining me today as a Canadian businessman,
lawyer,
member of parliament,
and the founder and head of the People's Party of Canada.
Maxine Bernay,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for the invitation,
Dave.
I'm very happy to be with you.
I am glad you're here.
I am pretty sure how many people are there in Canada,
roughly.
I turned 87 media and 37 so I've gotten about 36 million emails that you on the
show or on Twitter.
I mean everybody in Canada seems to want us to do this.
Sit down.
So,
so I'll do my best so we shall see what happens.
Okay.
There's many reasons that I'm looking forward to this chat.
And originally we were going to do this on Skype and then you were gracious
enough to say let's,
let's do this in person.
Um,
the fact that somebody in Canada is spreading the ideas of liberty and of the
individual and limited government,
all of those things is incredibly inspiring to me.
And it's war of what we need down here too.
But let's just start first with a little bit of your biography.
For people that don't know anything about you?
Yes.
Uh,
I'm a lawyer.
Um,
I did also of course in a businesses before,
um,
and I work in a private sector in Montreal,
Quebec,
uh,
in the financial sector.
I was VP of financial institutions.
And after that I work with the Montreal Economic Institute.
That's a free market think tanks,
like maybe the missus institute and the like that I was VP over there.
And in 2005,
um,
I had a meeting with Steven [inaudible] at that time.
He was the leader of the opposition before the election in 2006.
Uh,
and so he was looking for some ideas to be able to have some seats in Quebec.
As you know,
Quebec is the francophone part of the country.
And so we had a good chat together and I told him,
you know,
there's two important things that you must say to k Baker's if you want to win
first you must respect the constitution.
Because in Quebec,
if you remember,
we had the two referendum and uh,
we,
we still have a separate is a port,
it's called party at the provincial level.
So I told him,
you know,
respect the Canadian constitution,
don't interfere in provincial jurisdiction and everything will be okay.
And also lower taxes,
income tax,
a two k backers and all Canadians.
And at the end that was I think a good proposal for Quebec but also for,
uh,
all across the country.
And he decided to put that in his platform and he asked me to run with him in
2006.
So I decided to run.
And my writing,
my district,
it is in both near Quebec city.
It's Afa role,
f urban riding.
And I went there because my dad was an emp under Brian Maroney,
uh,
for uh,
13 years.
And so when I came in,
bought in 2006 a to run,
the director of my campaign told me,
Maxine,
we have a problem with you.
Uh,
because I was working in Montreal that was not tender writing.
It said,
you have a name.
My Dad was very well known,
but you don't have a first name.
So a goal at the end of the campaign,
people must know you.
So I did a good campaign and a at the end,
a one and all sorts.
Steven Opera.
We formed a Gartman in 2006 and minority government,
2008 a minority government.
And I was introduced to municipal at that time.
I did a big deregulation in telecom and that's why people are had that Dame,
the call me the uh,
Albert turn from Quebec because in Alberta they are very free markets.
And in Quebec at the plains Savalo we have a big fat and socialist government.
So,
and I do regret the telecom industry.
It was a big success.
And after that,
uh,
payments to our,
press me to be the finer fear and I was a foreign affair for a year and are
resigning.
And I came back in the cabinet in 2010.
And,
um,
I was a minister for Small Business and after dad,
a minister for a state for agriculture.
And so we had a majority government in 2000 and uh,
and uh,
11 and so we did some reform and after that in 2015 and two,
door went in power,
uh,
and uh,
and still a member of parliament and our per resigning as the leader of the
party and the fine is coming ray now because they decided to run for the
leadership and create after that,
I didn't win with the 49% of the votes and our wives,
they're mostly Bertoia and Kenny date.
And I had a very strong platform about individual freedom,
personal responsibility actually to four teams of our platform was individual
freedom,
personal restaurants,
MBT,
RF Becht and fairness.
And all our policies were based on these principles that was very successful at
49%.
And uh,
you know,
I was the only one to say we must abolish copwatch welfare.
While I'm good percent,
we might sort of saw card foreign aid and um,
and do a lot of changes like that on the economy and also on the immigration.
I had a strong platform,
so I didn't,
when I tried to work with the new leader,
um,
and we'll share,
uh,
trade to,
I wanted the leadership of the Conservative Party of Canada to add up some of
our reforms because that was very popular.
And a year later he told me that,
uh,
you didn't want me anymore.
They won't take any of our,
of the ideas that I put forward and our,
so I did couple of tweets that they didn't like,
uh,
I bought it to your dog.
And so,
um,
I resigned from the body and in September I decided to create the People's Party
of Canada.
Yeah.
All right.
So you're your basic yeah.
Political pedigree there.
Uh,
is there an inherent sort
of oddity of a libertarian trying to go into government where most people that
go into government want to grow government,
they believe that if only their policies were instituted,
they could have a better government that could do more and so on versus a
libertarian comes in,
you cut regulation,
you want it to cut some programs,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
It's almost like you're trying to shrink the thing that's also your job now.
You've had real jobs also.
So I suspect you could look at it perhaps a little bit differently.
Yeah.
Because you know,
it wasn't a private sector before and I know that too much government,
it is not bringing prosperity and um,
kind of an Australian economist also.
Uh,
I like muses and all the,
you know,
my,
my peripheral website is Mrs Org.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm a on the economy,
I can call,
you can call me battalion.
Um,
but um,
I'm not a really be tie in because it really brought,
Diana will ask for a opening borders or a norm,
more regulations or legislation on drugs.
And so I don't believe in that.
I think we must have a status
that we'll have some regulation,
basic regulations.
How do you figure out where that line is that that's been one of the things that
I talk about with a lot of different guests and that sort of seems to be a
little bit of the difference between people who consider themselves classical
liberals and libertarians where there's a little more say,
hand of the state.
On the classical liberal side.
Libertarians,
it's hard to know where the,
where the end is.
Are we,
are we just in Mad Max Mad Max was sometimes they call you mad.
Yeah.
So,
so for me it's,
it's on a bod the economy,
uh,
that's the most important.
Uh,
and yes.
Um,
you know,
our social policies must be for more freedom and personal responsibility.
And I tried to make a big difference with the state and the economy like we did
in the past with the states and,
and religious,
you know,
uh,
so that's always important to have this a difference.
And on the economy it's easy to be a libertarian and Apollo,
it's easier to be a difficult tie in,
in a politician,
uh,
because you know,
it's all special interest group that are coming to you.
And they want a,
a privilege or a or a or a more,
uh,
more,
subsidies or things like that.
So I'm making the line when I'm seeing,
you know,
what me,
what I want,
I want to work for all Canadians and not for a special interest group.
And when,
I don't know a in,
in group is coming to us and they just one to promote their privilege or to keep
their privilege,
that will be easy for me to say,
no,
I won't do that.
The best example or was the cocktail that we have in Canada in a,
in a supply management,
that's a socialist system that Pierre Trudeau put forward 45 years ago where a
meal can pull tree and eggs.
The producers fixing the price and fixing the production for the Canadian
market,
they cannot export.
So Canadians are paying twice the price for a meal,
poultry and eggs.
If you compound that with the price that you're paying here in the US.
So these cartel is very powerful.
And when they came to me and they wanted to keep their privilege,
I say,
no,
you know,
we'll abolish that.
We'll have a transition period.
You'll be able to export.
I believe in a real free market.
It's,
if a free market is good for every industry,
mostly be good also for these people.
So.
So what's the counter argument on that though?
We've trued,
oh now,
yeah.
Not The old Trudeau,
but if our current Trudy,
yeah,
was giving the counter argument on why you wouldn't free that up.
Is that just because he doesn't believe in free market economics,
but it's because it's a powerful lobby and I'll Saudia one to keep seats also.
And they are very powerful in rural areas in the country and uh,
and so far they're powerful.
Second,
uh,
he is buying in their arguments that,
you know,
uh,
if we have meal from the u s or eggs from the US,
that won't be the same quality.
And we need to stop that for being sure that we can control the quality of our
products.
And so that's another argument.
But for me,
you know,
when you have a legislation,
uh,
everybody in most respect dad,
so if you want to export to Canada,
your eggs or your poetry or your milk,
you must follow the Canadian legislation and regulation.
That's a,
that's a no deal.
And uh,
but it's,
it's,
it's the powerful,
they're very powerful.
So the thinking is they want to keep,
not only to adore but are also my former party,
the conservative party of Canada,
the NDP.
Also the,
they are too afraid to uh,
to just just listen to Canadians.
They think that all we have a good system and they think that can again,
the,
the thing that can Indians don't understand that system.
They didn't,
that Canadian don't understand that they are paying twice the price.
So the more I speak about that,
the more popular it is.
And that was very important in my campaign for the leadership.
And it is also part of our platform right now.
So answering your questions,
why it all want to keep that cartel iding it's only for political reason.
So is the idea of liberty and personal responsibility and some of the other
things that you're running on are these oddly new in Canada.
And I say that because when,
when you started coming on my radar about a year ago,
I saw people started tweeting about you.
There were a lot of people saying something to the effect of,
wow,
if a libertarian is needed in Canada,
then something really must be wrong there as if there was no need for it for a
long time.
But maybe something unique is happening now.
Yeah.
And people are ready for the new ideas.
And I think people are fed up with traditional politicians that are seeing
something,
a d and d opposing the auditee,
a politician that tried to please the special interest group.
So what I'm doing,
you know,
I'm doing politics differently and uh,
there is no political correctness,
uh,
for our party and seeing what,
what must be said for better policies in this country in Canada.
Sorry.
And so the,
um,
I think people are ready and,
and what's happening actually right now,
you know,
it's good to have the right ideas,
but it's good.
It's better to have the right ideas at the right time.
And I think the timing is very good for us,
for me because we have a government in a,
in a Taiwan right now are to total Gutterman that Horace spending on a ton of
money,
huge defecit people they don't see and we don't know when they will balance the
budget.
Uh,
it must be around 20,
24,
uh,
and everybody knows that,
that the different set of today or the taxes of tomorrow.
So a huge deficit,
huge taxes,
you know,
Taiwan and you kind of need is social right now in Canada.
So people are looking for a kind of alternative and a,
and I think that timing is good for me because,
uh,
in a,
in a Paul 57% of Canadians said,
and maybe a month ago that they're ready to vote for a new party.
So we are a very new party for months and month old and they are ready to vote
for a new party and not voting for the traditional parties.
Something is happening.
18 kit,
the big government in Ottawa,
every time putting a lot of regulations and a lot of subsidies to businesses.
Uh,
you know the governor,
they're loud.
Did GM a couple of years ago,
more than two point $5 billion and GM said,
uh,
two months ago that they will leave Canada.
So it's a waste of money and we're giving a lot of money to big businesses and
all the other politicians are saying,
yeah,
it's all key.
We Must Elf business.
What I'm saying,
yes we might l businesses,
but every businesses having a fair policy that is to lower taxes to every
businesses and not giving a subsidies and beaking winner and loser.
So I think people are ready for a change.
They're seeing what's happening in our country and they know that we're not
going in the right direction right now.
So let's talk a little bit about regulation,
because I think a lot of people think,
especially if they're on the left right now,
they think if you say,
I'm cutting regulation,
well first they go to environmental regulations.
Yeah.
I think that's what they think first.
So I do want to ask me about that.
Yeah.
But also they think if you're just talking about a purely at a business level,
then that means that capitalism will then run a mock call.
It,
you know,
that all of these businesses will then start dumping in the rivers and doing
shady deals with each other and competition will be crushed and all of those
things.
So you want to do business or,
or environment first on the regulation front.
Yeah.
I think let's do,
let's do business first and then,
yeah.
And then let's do business first.
Uh,
you know,
business most answered the needs of consumers.
So consumers are asking for better products and for a m products that's,
that will respect the environment.
Uh,
that's why they are asking for electric cars.
And so you don't always need regulation to force that.
The free markets,
the,
uh,
the wish of the people will force businesses to adapt their practice in the
right way.
And so when you have,
when you have a real free market and when you have competition,
it's always good at the end for the consumers.
You'll have a better products and you'll have a lower prices.
But at the same thing,
the way,
at the same time,
the way that they are producing their products will change.
Right now,
you know,
people the best.
And some people are telling me,
you know,
we must have a,
cooperate to a social,
uh,
um,
corporate.
I do call that corporate social or corporate welfare.
No one will corporate social identity,
a corporation,
my son be socially well.
Oh,
they have like the social awareness,
social awareness.
And I said,
you know,
not really because a corporation first must make profits.
If they don't make any profit,
the they won't.
They won't be able to do anything.
So if they are profitable,
it's because you want their peak consumer consumers who wants their goods and
products.
So that's the first goal of our cooperation.
To make products and I think that you need regulation.
But,
uh,
what we're doing right now,
every time that something happened,
we put a new regulation,
but they must be a responsible of their actions,
corporations and individuals or that that's important for me.
And I think Canadian understand that.
Yeah.
What about on the environmental side?
I think this is the big one.
I think you've been for people who can understand free market economics.
It's a little bit more,
people think you just can't leave this environmental issues up to two private
companies.
Yeah.
You know,
you can sue a corporation if they don't respect the regulations.
Actually,
you know,
clean the water.
It's very important.
But you know,
uh,
when you have facilities that are owned by the government or by the
municipalities,
uh,
everything must be public.
If they're doing tests and,
and things like that.
Uh,
if the water is been on night,
when it's not public,
you cannot,
uh,
you cannot sue them if they don't,
if they don't respect the regulation.
So I remember that Margaret,
or in Europe,
the way to clean water over there was to have a regulation saying every test
that you're doing and that was done by municipalities or public entity must be
public and you will be responsible to be sure that you respect the regulations.
Should she just put a resolution on that?
Every test was public and five years later the wider Watsky nerd.
I didn't,
it was before because he didn't want to be sued.
They didn't want to be so,
so they were responsible.
So when you have a real free market,
when everything is on the table and you know the information that's bring,
usually a better quality of the water or land.
And so you have property right for that and property rights.
It's the basics of,
of all that.
But speaking about the environment now,
the debate in Canada,
it's climate change.
Yeah.
So,
so everybody wants to do something about climate change.
And I'm the only party who said,
you know,
we won't do anything,
uh,
environment in car data share jurisdiction with provinces and the federal
government.
And I don't believe in the Paris accord.
I don't believe that Canada would be able to achieve the goals that they put
into Paris accord.
And actually,
uh,
the UN and the radical environmental in Canada that said the same thing,
that Twitter one to impose a carbon tax of $20 a ton and he must impose a carbon
tax off at least $200 a time if you want to achieve his target.
So at $20 at times it will be on there.
Distortion for the economy and odd working families would appear with PR your
prices.
So that's why,
you know,
I don't believe in Paris accord and I think that we must not impose Paul's new
regulation on that.
We must lead provinces and a provincial government if they want to have a cap in
trade like they have here in the US and other kind of a process for that.
For us,
uh,
I want to have a program that will maybe be very strong on Clearwater or clear
here,
something that people understand and having the property to rates,
uh,
that will work and more information.
You need more than
formation at the same time to be sure that people won't understand if this lake
is clear on that.
Yeah.
So I'm glad you mentioned that because it seems to me that it's about
information and being able to get your messaging across.
So for example,
the Paris accords,
which obviously the United States pulled out of it seems very easy.
If you listen to the media,
it was very easy.
We have to be part of the Paris accords.
And then if you ask anyone what the Paris accords are,
they have no idea.
If you ask them when was was a binding,
is there any,
you know,
um,
is there anyone watching to make sure any of them this happens?
They have no idea in the answer's no.
I just read last month that despite the,
uh,
despite the US pulling out of the accords,
that right now the US is meeting most if not or exceeding all of the standards
of the,
of course.
So how much of this is just about getting your messaging across because,
uh,
this will shift us a little bit to talking about the media,
which you've had an interesting relationship with.
Yeah,
you're right about that.
You know,
it's all about to virtue senior link for a politician.
And,
but I think Canadian understand that they understand when I'm seeing,
you know,
the total government,
I truly,
right now there are a procreate or saying something to the population knowing
that he won't be able to achieve that.
So I prefer to tell the truth thing,
you know,
we won't sing that and we won't do to achieve that and we won't spend two point
$3 billion to send that to African countries to El them to fight climate change.
I think we must help Canadian first.
So that's part of our platform.
But the other party,
like the Conservative Party also,
they don't want to have a carbon tax when they want to impose more regulations,
uh,
on Canadian businesses.
And that's not the solution.
But they,
they try to please maybe the media,
but also a portion of the population.
And I think that,
you know,
when you explained,
and that's what I like in politics,
you know,
I like to explain our policies and why we are,
we are having the right policies based on freedom and response.
Lbt and when you explain that,
the more you explain,
I think the better people understand it and do more,
um,
uh,
more people will want to vote for our party.
So for me,
when I'm the only one to speak against the Paris accord,
uh,
there are a huge clientele there and it won't hurt me.
It will help me at the end.
And,
uh,
and you know,
my,
my deal with Canadians is be true.
Tell what you believe in and have some debates,
real debates.
And that's important for me.
So yes,
the media are playing an important role,
but we need to use all sorts of social media and that's why,
you know,
uh,
I'm very pleased to be here to speak to the American audience and Canadians
audience and just tried to have a conversation with them anew.
Yeah.
Well,
what's the state of the media?
Yeah,
you guys have,
you guys have a whole different set of problems than what is going on with the
CBC and just everything else in Canada.
I know we have to CBC,
like how your whole body language.
Yeah.
We have to CBC and the Federal Government is giving about one point $3 billion a
year to the state,
uh,
broadcast or to CBC.
And in French it's heads you Canada.
And I'm the only politician and it's,
it's a very popular policy that we must cut that because it is unfair to CBC are
competing with other private broadcaster,
uh,
for the advertising,
and also the received money from the government.
So it is not fair.
We must cut the CBC and a,
and what I want,
I want the CBC to be a little bit like a PBS in the state.
If they're so good,
they will be able to have money from their viewers.
But also the CBC,
uh,
their editorial board are a little bit,
I will be very,
uh,
very kind look a bit the left ear.
So,
yeah.
So very,
Yeah.
And uh,
it's worse in French door.
They're agile.
Canada in French are a more left ears then CBC sometimes.
So is there a reason for that?
You know,
uh,
it's like your media here.
It's a bit,
but,
but the worst thing is it is funded by the government.
So if you're a,
I dunno,
a CNN and you don't receive any fumble,
you government and you want to to be on the left,
if it's your corporate decision,
but the CBC must be more neutral and they are not.
So that's the big problem that we have in Canada.
The way to fix that,
it's first of all,
CBC must be a must receive money from the viewers first and second.
Uh,
the government,
if the government is giving money to CBC,
we must know the,
uh,
what's happening and maybe the executive of the CBC must be before the
parliament once a year to explain their editorial policy.
But that being said,
uh,
the media,
we have the CBC,
we have the traditional media.
But when you're a real conservative or right wing politician,
uh,
you don't have the same coverage than the,
the Liberals or the left.
Uh,
they're having in these traditional media,
do you think in a weird way that that's working to your favor now?
Because at least in the circles that I can see,
you seem to be the hottest Canadian politician despite the fact,
and it's,
maybe it's fueled by,
maybe it's not despite maybe because of the fact that you're the outsider from
the media and people are so fed up with the media that it's like,
oh,
here,
here's this guy doing it,
you know,
circumventing them.
And also,
you know,
um,
uh,
when the media,
the traditional media or writing something about us or my party,
that is not true.
I will call that.
I will.
Uh,
and I'm very,
very factual on,
on,
on social media and Twitter about it.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't try to please everybody or I don't know how to please the media.
They have to do a job.
If they are fair,
it's okay.
If they are not fair,
I will be out there.
And,
uh,
and I will,
I will argue my case.
And that's not all,
all the Polish and the Polish.
I'm not doing that.
They want to be fine with the media.
They don't want to have a fight with the media.
And for me,
I to have a fight with a jaundiced,
uh,
if a is not doing his job.
And I think people,
I appreciate that.
So yes,
when they're doing something,
not,
um,
objective on our policies,
on my party,
that can help me at the end because you know,
the credibility of journalists,
it is not the same with people like you on social media.
People have another way to find your news and they're a little bit more critics,
a tower,
the traditional journalists and yes,
I agree with you.
That can help me.
Yeah.
As a politician,
are you able to debate some of your political opponents these days?
I mean,
does anyone in Canada put these kinds of talks on a television where you can
actually get into the ideas with some of the people that you disagree with?
No,
usually when I'm on the traditional TV in Canada,
it's all about,
you know,
five minutes,
six minutes you don't want to get yeah.
Sounds like,
yeah,
yeah.
They wanted the only to have it.
And they don't give you enough time to insert the questions and then to go
deeper in the subject.
Uh,
but that's why I use social media.
That's why I'm prison in social media.
So,
but you know,
I need to deal with that and I think it's going very well right now.
So how does this all link to just sort of a state of free speech in Canada
because there does something seem to be something particularly unique in Canada,
which is why I've had so many Canadian guests and why Canada is usually our
second or third most viewed country.
Obviously there was the Jordan Peterson incident with [inaudible].
Yeah,
there's what happened with w uh,
Lindsay Shepherd at Wilfrid Laurier.
Yay.
You've got Gad sat up there.
Who's,
who's always fighting the battle of free speech.
Is there something,
is there,
is this new,
what's happening related to political correctness in Canada?
Yeah.
I think first of all,
that started 40 years ago in the university in Canada,
like in the US.
But now what's happening,
there are some politicians who believe in that and with that motion m one or
tree to be able to see 16.
Now these people that were,
that were on the at school couple of years ago,
40 years ago now,
some of them are politicians and,
uh,
you have this debate right now and it's,
it's good for us that we have Jordan Peterson and people like that.
Um,
we must fight,
I think,
when must not take for granted in Canada or freedom of expression and free
speech and,
and we must fight.
And I'm doing that as a politician.
Uh,
and you know,
would,
would that build see 16,
that was crazy.
Bill.
You know,
Jordan,
they want to force his Jordan to,
uh,
speak with a trans or gender.
Uh,
not he or she bought,
what was the word?
Oh,
it was whatever they want.
Whatever they want.
Yeah,
yeah.
But there no obligation.
You know,
there's no obligation to please everybody.
And that's what this all comes down to though,
that people just don't understand it.
And the fundamental responsibility of government in a freezer side.
I mean,
if we were boiling all this into one thing,
that seems to me to be it.
Yeah.
You don't want the government to tell you what to do.
You don't want the government to tell you what to say.
You know,
it's the basics of our democracy.
And actually,
you know,
one of our candidate,
look,
I Lynn,
because we're,
we have a f three by elections in Canada at the end of February,
the 25th of February.
And I will have candidates and people are party of Canada.
We'll have candidate.
And one of our candidates look alien in BC,
um,
uh,
Brunette BBC.
In that writing,
she add the Prion Shola Ball,
uh,
fied for,
um,
uh,
gender against the gender fluidity in BC in discord.
It's a provincial jurisdiction they wanted to teach at school,
to young kids that if you're a boy,
you may not be a boy.
And if you're a,
you may not be a girl and you can choose your sex.
The state wants to impose that and to teach that to young people and look at the
inch.
And Noah,
I don't want that.
I don't want the state to tell us what to do.
And that must be the responsibility of the parents.
So you don't have to put that in the mind of a young boys,
six or seven or five years old.
So,
but when she decided to be our candidate,
all the mainstream media as all Bernie and I said,
you know,
she has the right to our own opinion and that's a great debate that they had at
the provincial level.
Now she's doing politics.
I've definitely level,
but you know,
they were trying,
they were trying to look at her like,
you know,
she may be a crazy Kenny Dade because she,
she,
she has some,
some opinions and strong opinions.
But you know,
because I believe in freedom of speech and our candidates can have opinions like
that.
We have candidates that are pro choice.
We have candidates that are poor life by just staying to adorn the liberals.
They don't want any pro life candidates.
So for me,
my party must be like the,
the,
uh,
our Canadian society.
So yes,
I will tolerate different point of view,
but people must be all behind our programs.
A program that's very important.
But yes,
we have these debates right now in Canada about the state imposing some,
some values that a,
I think that's not the role of government.
Is it actually part of the policy of the Trudeau government that you,
if you're a pro life,
that you actually can't be,
you know,
it's still in the party platform.
It's a party platform.
If you're a pro life person,
you cannot be a candidate for the Liberal Party of Canada.
And just staying to the door said that.